harvest your crops and pop your pimples
because we have scary stories to tell in
the dark yes if Auguste couldn't get any
scarier with the release of Dora the
Explorer we have Guillermo del Toro's
latest screenplay in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into the ending and
explaining some of these badass monsters
along the way so here we go scary
stories begins on Halloween of 1968 in
the small town of Mill Valley
Pennsylvania and it's no wonder this
town is called Mill Valley as the local
paper mill is at the core of all the
spooky happenings spooky when local
teenagers Stella Oggy hormone and chuck
break into the abandoned bellows place a
house known for its child murders they
uncover the secret room of Sarah bellows
Sarah was the daughter of do dot bellows
the owner of the town's paper mill in
the late 1800s she was born with a rare
condition of albinism making her body
pale white and causing her family to
lock her in the basement away from the
local townspeople Sarah would spend her
time in the basement telling stories
through the wall to local children and
writing them in her book with her own
blood but Sarah held a darker secret she
knew that her father's paper mill was
responsible for the deaths of the
townspeople
mercury from the mill had spread into
the water and poisoned many of mill
valleys inhabitants so when Stella on
the gang take her book it unleashes the
full rage of Sarah bellows hell-bent on
destroying anything that comes in her
way the book begins to target one kid
per day writing a story in blood which
eventually comes true the first victim
is Tommy and a story simply titled
Harold named after the beautiful
scarecrow Tommy loves to beat the [ __ ]
out of her
as Harold comes to life he stabs Tommy
with a pitchfork eventually turning him
into his scarecrow himself ironic that
the thing Tommy hated is the thing that
he becomes and worst of all the game
finds out that the book can't be
destroyed or discarded when Stella
brings the book back to the mansion it
somehow ends up right back in her room
or when they decide to light it on fire
it emerges completely unscathed
the second victim is Augie whose story
is called the big toe a story told to
him by his father when he was a kid in
which a corpse
comes looking for it's missing big toe a
big toe that was in the stew he ate for
dinner he's captured by a character
simply known as the toe monster but by
the end of the film he's still missing
leaving room for a sequel the attack on
Oggy Spurs the gang to look into the
death of Sarah bellows they stop at
their local newspaper and dig up
articles from 1898 the year Sarah
apparently hung herself with her own
hair the papers reported that a servant
of the bellos Manor
Lulu Baptiste had taught Sarah black
magic which was used to kill the
townspeople but before they can check up
on Lulu the book begins to write its
next story the red spot referring to
Ruth's massive pimple that puts even my
worst high schools into shame
Ruth survives his attack after dozens of
spiders hatch out of her face
prompting the gang to hasten their
search for answers by questioning Lulu
Baptiste the bellows former servant who
apparently had taught Sarah black magic
they find Lulu but she's blind and
seemingly suffering from some form of
delirium nevertheless she tells them two
new pieces of key information that Sarah
was never taught black magic and that
she didn't hang herself at home as the
legend said rather at a psychiatric
hospital a psychiatric hospital Stella
and Ramon later visit and find out was
the location where Sarah was brutally
tortured via electroshock therapy her
family wanted her to admit that their
mill had nothing to do with the deaths
in town something that would be patently
false unfortunately it's also at this
hospital that the next story occurs the
dream a reference to Charlie's dream he
had in the Red Room while visited by a
pale lady and that's exactly what
happens
Charlie is consumed by the pea lady in a
room that's not only the color red but
the re d stands for records and
evaluation department the second-last
monster is the jangly man in a story
called NEET I go to Walker a lyric that
the monster sings in the printed version
of the story the jangly man is a
decomposing corpse that can stitch or
rip apart pieces of its body at will fun
fact the jangly man is performed by an
actual contortionist by the name of Troy
James who you may have seen on America's
Got Talent
the jangly man is after Ramone calling
him a coward as we learn earlier in the
story Ramone is on the run because he's
a draft dodger after his brother was
killed in Vietnam he decided to live out
of his car in order to avoid the draft
and that's one of the great things about
these monsters their stories all somehow
relate to the characters for example
Ramone whose brother was blown to pieces
is now literally chased by a creature
who is in pieces or Ruth a woman focused
on looking her best is scarred by a
spider-infested pimple the monsters have
become reality because of the stories
the characters learned as children for
example chuck's comes from a dream
Auggie a story his dad told him and
Ramon a campfire story he was told as a
child with limited time left
Ramon distracts the jangly man while
Stella goes after Sara in the abandoned
house if she can tell Sara that they
know she was innocent perhaps they can
put an end to her madness and that's
exactly what happens the final story the
haunted house sees Stella confront the
final monster Sara still a tells her
that she'll make sure Sara's story gets
out there that the truth of her
innocence and what her family did will
be revealed
Sara hands her an ink pen and makes her
write the story in blood
because who doesn't like a story written
in good old-fashioned blood and with
that Sara's soul is put to rest and the
jangly man is destroyed along with it
Sara has redeemed herself and learned
from Stella that the rage she projected
onto innocent people is no different
than how her family dealt with her even
though she was innocent the film ends
with Stella saying goodbye to Ramon who
has made the decision to fight in
Vietnam his character arc was one of
coward to hero his fight with the jangly
man has allowed him to muster the
courage to fight abroad rather than run
away from the thing that scared him the
most
similarly Stella has also changed at the
beginning of the film she's asked by
Oggy if she's going to hand in her
stories to the school paper but she
doesn't because she's not confident in
her own writing at the end we see her
win multiple awards for her work and she
tells us that if anything Sara taught
her never to give up and never giving up
is where the story ends with Stella Ruth
and her father venturing away from Mill
Valley to find a way to save Oggy and
Chuck paving the way for an eventual
sequel but
period of 1968 is also very interesting
because of its social commentary
sixty-eight was a time of great change
and so to do our characters go through
their own big changes it was a time
filled with monsters of its own kind
like Nixon who tried to hide the truth
about Vietnam and Watergate from the
American people just like the bellows
family tried to hide the truth about
their poisonous paper mill from the
community scary stories although not
really bringing anything new to the
genre is a fun well-executed horror I
want to hear your thoughts below and
make sure to LIKE and subscribe I got
more videos on the way and you can
follow me on twitter at think story
whitey and until next time remember
daddy loves you very much